Wow welcome to seven tips for effective
remote learning with Khan Academy my
name is Megan ppattani and I head up US
teacher education here at Khan Academy
and I'm joined today by my colleague
Jeremy who leads our teacher success
team so just a little heads up today
we're going to be covering tips and best
practices for remote teaching and
learning again Jeremy and I are really
here to help support teachers and
students as they navigate this remote
remote learning experience Jeremy and I
are both former educators and we try to
do our best to put ourselves in your
shoes going through this very chaotic
time I'm gonna try our best to provide
clear and actionable steps using Khan
Academy wherever possible just a heads
up today we will not be covering account
setup or how to get started if you want
to learn more about how to get started
with Khan Academy I recommend using the
link below in order to access our Quick
Start Guide if you want a full copy of
the slides and all the links attached in
the handouts tab of GoToWebinar you'll
find a full copy of the slides from
today's presentation so why use Khan
Academy for remote learning well Khan
Academy is built to serve learners
anywhere at any time you can assign
specific skills to practice or you can
have students practice and get instant
feedback you're able to keep track of
student progress even when you're not
together which right now we know is more
important than ever
Khan Academy is built to serve learners
anywhere at any time you don't
necessarily need a computer everything
students can access on the web can be
accessed on a smartphone so if you have
students with limited access they'll
still be able to reach valuable content
and our content is available in over 40
languages and all for free Khan Academy
is a nonprofit with a goal to support
high
excuse-me high quality education for
anyone anywhere so let's start here and
while this may feel a little bit obvious
I think sometimes when teachers and
students jump into remote learning those
valuable communication skills that you
rely on every day
I seem to fall apart so think about when
you go into your classroom when you walk
into your classroom in the morning you
never think I'm not going to talk to my
students all day of course you're going
to communicate with them and for some of
your students you are the most important
relationship that they have every day
and so now more than ever your students
are in need of consistent communication
so if you and your students can connect
live absolutely do it even if it's a
learning curve for you and for them
there's some really great tools out
there like hangouts meet which a lot of
teachers to give live video lessons and
record them for students to watch later
there are a bunch of other tools that
are now offering their video streaming
services for free so feel free to take a
look and have you have the opportunity
to connect with your students live I
absolutely support taking that dive
layer you students know you're thinking
about them so if you can't connect live
or even if you have time beyond that
which I know is a stretch right now send
them a note via email or an athelete
classdojo
find a way to communicate with your
students let them know that you're
missing them I think students right now
are really hungry for that opportunity
for social connection and getting a note
from you as a teacher someone who's so
meaningful in their lives telling them
that you miss them and how excited
you'll be to see them again
it really has a deeper meaning and
please please please provide feedback a
lot of students have been given a bunch
of work to do while they're at home but
if they're just given the work with no
feedback how do they know that that work
has meaning how do they know that
they're doing things correctly so please
if you've given your students work to do
while they're remote make sure that
you're giving them qualitative feedback
as well here's a couple of examples
we're seeing from our teacher community
so at the top we have a teacher who says
she was channeling her inner SOUTHCOM
and she used video chat to whiteboard
live with students and down below we
have one of our ambassadors who combines
flipgrid
and combines Khan Academy and Creed's
videos for his students in order to know
that he's thinking about them and they
and he can message each other back then
let's talk about communication between
students and between you
their families so while that
communication between you and your
students is so essential students are
also missing each other and so using
something like Google Docs or slides
allowing students to collaborate or
communicate in real time around shared
problems and ideas is a great
opportunity we see a lot of teachers
maybe taking a sample problem so they
look at Khan Academy and they see a
problem that a lot of students have
answered incorrectly and they'll throw
it on a Google slide and then each
student can add a subsequent slide
showing their work on how they would
solve the problem and students can leave
comments saying oh that's what I missed
or great job so that way your students
are still able to collaborate in a way
similar to what they would do in class
also don't forget about parents and
Families right many of you I'm sure are
now becoming both a full-time
stay-at-home parent and a full-time work
from home teacher and so think about
some of those others families who are in
your shoes we're all working remotely on
this journey together and if possible
trying to reach out to one family per
week just to share something their
student might be doing well or something
you you know know about their student
that's really exciting and don't
hesitate to let parents and guardians
know how much you appreciate them for
supporting their child through this
process of remote learning this is a
really hard jump for parents and to get
a little high-five from the teacher
saying you know what you're really doing
a great job putting that effort in that
can make a huge huge difference
and don't forget each other great I'm so
excited to see so many people on here
today because we really are stronger
together and don't forget to reach out
to your other teachers teachers you work
with daily that you're used to
communicating with members of maybe your
peer learning community and just your
teacher friends they're going through
this transition as well so don't
hesitate to share best practices or just
check in on each other
and if you're looking for a way to
communicate with them use some of the
same tools you already using with your
students
number two choose the best tools and
stay with them choose the tools that are
best for you and your students there's a
lot of noise right now around digital
tools and there's all sorts of things
you can use for remote learning but you
know your classroom best so start with
things that you've already been using if
you've been using Khan Academy all year
great
please keep using us if you were looking
for new tools pick what fits you and
your students I don't know your
classroom better than you do and neither
does anyone else
and so find what fits your students and
use that and make sure you're not
switching it every day every week
because students we want them to focus
on what they're learning we want them to
learn new skills in math or English
language arts or foreign languages we
don't want them worrying about stress
over new tools so if you find what's
right stick with it number three keep a
schedule and we know this is much easier
said than done
but sticking to consistent times for
working and connecting with students is
really important and as we're trying to
keep schedules for students we also want
to try and keep schedules for ourselves
it helps give a rhythm today to the day
and to our organization so find times
for you to lesson plan connect with
students find times for you to take a
break and if you're looking for examples
because this is a really big adventure
for a lot of us we've got you covered
South Khan is put together key schedules
for all different age groups so you'll
see on your screen right now an example
for our elementary school students and
example for our middle school students
and an example for our high school
students what should you be thinking
about what might your students need and
you'll see this is not just sitting in
front of their computer for eight hours
things like getting outside and playing
finding time to read and reflect all of
those things are there for them and
definitely teachers are great in
adapting resources so if this is a great
base for you take it and make it your
own
number four support independent learning
and I know a lot of us are always trying
to find ways for our students to gain
independence and really take ownership
and agency of their learning and so with
remote opportunities we can encourage
our students to really take hold of that
and to master new skills so using Khan
Academy's mastery system students can
set students can use mastery goals to
work below on or above grade levels and
students can move at their own pace
they're always welcome to go back and
review content or move ahead they can
even work on subjects outside what they
would normally do inside your classroom
some teachers might encourage students
to move a course below or course ahead
in the same content area or I even know
one math teacher who wants students who
master their grade level in math
encourage them to find something that
they're passionate about and really dive
into master skills in that area so
encourage your students to take a little
ownership of their learning now and move
ahead or review concepts that make them
feel really confident in their learning
and if you're looking for more guidance
on how to tactically do this the link at
the bottom of this slide will take you
to a how-to article on setting up course
mastery goals for your students and this
here's is a quick animation so for those
of you or that are familiar with the
Khan Academy platform if you go to your
teacher dashboard and into your class
course mastery on the left hand side as
you see the image doing
click placement and create goal again I
highly recommend if you'd like to do
this with your students you access the
article and it'll take you step-by-step
through the process number five motivate
your students
now I know a lot of you were thinking
this is hard enough to do in person how
am I supposed to do this when I don't
even get to see my students every day
well we know motivation is hard and it's
even harder now
so one thing we recommend is setting
clear goals and maybe you had goals
before but use this as a great
opportunity to revisit them or maybe as
a class you want to set goals for while
you remove what is something that we as
a class can achieve and include her
students in the process students really
love being part of their own learning so
often do we get the question why am i
learning this will include your students
in the conversation either make them
individual or as an entire class focus
on what they want to achieve in this
time period and then communicate that
back with the student and with families
again think back to our earlier
conversation around communication
involve families tell them what your
students are working towards and if you
want more information again these links
are all included in the slides in the
handout tab of GoToWebinar and will be
included in a follow-up email I
recommend using that link to learn a
little bit more about mastery goals and
why we recommend using them with
students and don't forget to recognize
milestones right in the classroom if
students perform well if they do well on
an individual assignment or they're
showing growth or perseverance we
recognize that and really make our
students really celebrated well it's a
little bit trickier we know to do at a
distance and so why don't you try
recommending a you know virtual
certificate of achievement or a
celebratory video things like flipgrid
allow you to do quick free videos to
students when if you're looking for
certificates related to Khan Academy
we've got you covered that link will
take you to a handful of Khan Academy
certificates you can share digitally
with your students and they come in a
variety of languages so they should
reach a fair number of your students
one's a pretty big one and I think this
is one that adults just as much as kids
are struggling with is recognize the
emotional impact that everything that's
going around right now remote learning
is about more than just curriculum I
think we've seen a lot in the media over
the past couple weeks about how students
are gonna keep learning and keep hitting
goals and those things it's more than
just curriculum you as a teacher know
that being a teacher is not just about
reaching a standard so make sure that as
we're going through and worrying about
all the things students have to learn
that we take a moment to pause and think
about the emotional impact this is
having on our students in our
communities and some teachers recommend
switching out an assignment and instead
replacing it with an opportunity for
students to write and reflect on what's
going on maybe you have a question for
discussion or maybe just to open
reflection and again thinking back on
some of the things we talked about
earlier using a tool like Google Docs
and students can share that and leave
supportive comments to each other so
you're giving students an opportunity to
reflect on the emotional toll and that
this experience is having on them and
allowing them an opportunity to
communicate with each other and be
supportive even when they can't be with
each other in person express gratitude I
think this is the thing we can all work
on I know I certainly can with our
students and our communities in general
but taking a moment to you know send a
brief email or again a message in
something like classdojo
to encourage teachers and students to
share their appreciation students who
are still completing all of their
assignments or maybe reaching out to you
for something more or students who are
asking for help obviously it's gonna
take them an extra bit of effort for
them to ask for help right now recognize
and appreciate the effort your students
are putting in and I bet you'll see a
lot of that returned back at school I
worked at we used to have an option
where we would send five messages to
students once a week our five messages
to students families once a week and it
was just a way to recognize students and
let their families know that we
appreciate them and things our students
are doing and not just your high
Seavers you know across the board
students that are doing something even
if it's not academic base that you
really want to recognize that and then
you'll get a lot of really supportive
things back I promise you and how much
families and students appreciate all the
time and effort you're putting in right
now and throughout the year also promote
learning and that emotional piece is not
just about the students it's about you
too and I think we've seen a lot about
the effect it's having on students but
don't forget this is really hard and
this is a lot to take in at once so be
honest with yourself and be honest with
your students share with your students
and let them know it's okay to struggle
with a new tool or a new concept I can
tell you the team here at Khan Academy
we've been trying to learn new tools all
week so that we can reach all of you and
when we opened up about how we're
struggling to learn these tools it was
great to hear everybody else say you
know what me too and so it's okay to
open up with your students and say this
is a lot to take in this is a lot to
learn and it's okay to struggle and
we're gonna get through it together and
if you're looking for additional
resources on things like that please
feel free to check out our content on
growth mindset then it's a great
starting point to talk about productive
struggle and things like that with
students last but certainly not least
and I think this ties in right with
recognizing the emotional piece it's cut
yourself and your students a break be
realistic you are not going to cover
everything you wouldn't class and you
know what that's okay and so to take a
step back and realize that you are
putting in the effort to keep your
students mentally engaged is a huge
achievement in and of itself so if you
need to choose a couple of key standards
or concepts to focus on think about what
are the most essential for students to
understand most of our teachers are
recommending two or three a week for
students to work on and you know what if
one week you only get to one that's okay
again cut yourself some slack none of
this is easy and as you transition and
as you and your students get more
comfortable you'll find that you can get
more done and so again if you're
thinking about those two or three
concepts per week if you want to use
assignments on Khan Academy
most teachers have told us that three to
five assignments per week covers the
right amount of content for about two to
three you know standards or concepts and
reaches about thirty to forty five
minutes per week on Khan Academy and we
found that that benchmark is really
really important for students to see
growth and if you're looking for more on
assignments again please utilize these
slides after the presentation and that
link will take you to a video on how to
create assignments using Khan Academy
and now I want to make sure we have time
to open it up to questions and if you
want to have anything more specific or
you're having trouble with any of the
technical pieces please reach out to our
Help Center up again a link here and
feel free to share these slides with
other educators and if you want to share
feedback please let us know as well we
are trying to gather as much information
from educators and teachers like
yourself about what they're doing that's
working well and what has been a really
great learning for them but they wish
they could share with other teachers so
I'm gonna pause here and I'm gonna reach
out to Jeremy and Jeremy's gonna share a
couple of our questions that are coming
in all right so first of all thank you
so much Megan for leading this year bill
actually says
you
you
and if you look here you'll see total
learning minute skills leveled up in
skills without progress so this shows
the total learning minutes for each of
my students so I can get a quick glance
at how long my students have spent on
the site and then in terms of their
skills how many they've leveled up and
how many they have not made progress on
which means they either level down or
they've stayed at the same level if I
click on an individual student here I'll
be able to see my exercise minutes and
my total learning minute so these are
the two numbers I was referencing 77 is
the total learning minutes I've spent on
the site on any Content where's the 28
minutes are the minutes that I've spent
engaged with questions and so for all of
your students you'll be able to see that
and for each activity on this individual
student report you'll be able to see
exactly how many too many minutes
they've spent on each of these items as
you can see this is a demo account so
there's not a lot here but that you'd be
able to see how much time they've spent
on each item cool thank you so much
clear for that great question and thanks
Megan for showing them exactly where to
find it
let's step back from the technology for
a second another question says what are
some of the norms that we get set up for
virtual learning we all have route rules
and guidelines and our physical
classrooms how do we bring that same
sense of culture and expectations to the
virtual environment yeah I think it's a
really great question and a really
important one I think what happens
sometimes is that a lot of teachers as
they move digital forget that those same
concepts apply things like you know
class management in class culture are
still really valuable and in some cases
even more valuable now so for example if
you decide to go live with your students
like a fair number of teachers we know
are set up the first time you're doing
it or if you haven't had an opportunity
start Monday take what you would think
of as your norms and expectations and
display them to your students and go
through them and if you're not sure what
your norms feel right for your classroom
make it an opportunity for an
interactive activity with your students
again you could do it in a discussion
format if you're using something like
hangouts meet students can put
suggestions in the chat
on the right-hand side if you're using
something where students can post
comments or post votes allow them to
choose what should be our norm should
our norms be that anyone can add to the
chat at once should our norms be that we
need to raise a hand icon if we want to
contribute to the class discussion
should our norms be that we only meet
live twice a week I think that really
involving your students in what should
be those norms now that you've gone
digital that should be an opportunity
for you if you feel really comfortable
and know what the norm should be for
your classroom already make sure you're
communicating those well and make sure
that you're following through on them
they're really easy to get off task so
for example when I would work remote
with students one of the things that I
would say is the norm is I could close
off all of my social tabs while I was in
class if I was teaching my class
remotely then that was where my focus
was and so making sure that my cell
phone was on silent and that my you know
Twitter feed was was muted and things
like that so making if that's the norm
make sure you're modeling that behavior
for your students you're not on your
your hangout or your video you know
distracted by something else which I
know that example can be easier said
than done but again setting those norms
communicating them clearly and modeling
them tends to be a really helpful for
and again if you're able to do that then
your students will be encouraged to do
the same : speaking of modeling Megan I
think hopefully what we were seeing
through this webinar today is what's
possible for your own students whether
you use a tool like GoToWebinar or zoom
or Google meetings or whatever your
district provides you always have the
ability to have questions chats even
live polls kind of like a hoot baked
into your webinar so definitely lots of
ways that keep students engaged even a
tough learning environment yeah I
wouldn't double down that to Jeremy as
you think about this again as someone
mentioned the hope was to share some
tools that go beyond the scope of Khan
Academy and that we really can can give
some ideas as you take this remote
learning adventure and don't be afraid
to mix and match your tools together so
when I was teaching
my students really enjoyed combining a
video tool so they would be on live
camera with each other with Kahoot so
that that way they were doing review
questions and they were doing it in a
social way but they were all in their
own homes at night and so don't be
afraid to try something and again
take these tips as guidance and fit them
right teachers are great at adapting
things to their own classrooms so don't
be afraid to take you know tools you're
already using and adapting some of the
tips that we've shared to fit you best
cool
so another sort of psychological
question here and this is coming in from
Maddy Maddy says how do I actually
encourage my students to complete Khan
Academy assignments given I don't have
that impress in contact and that I build
and motivate them day to day yeah great
question so a couple of things are built
into the platform and let me show you
just in case you for those who might be
a little less familiar with the Khan
Academy experience on every course for
Khan Academy that's mastery enabled
you'll see that each of these offer kind
of a gamification piece where students
are earning mastery points for achieving
progress on skills lessons and units and
so MS students work through content and
I'm going to jump into a unit here as
students work through material they'll
see their levels go up and their skills
move to mastered and they'll see these
little icons start to fill out and so as
they do this they earn mastery points
and badges and they can upgrade their
avatars on their own profile page so
there aren't some gamification pieces
built into Khan Academy now we know that
works for some students and definitely
not for all and so again to the question
of I'm not there in person I can't put
my chart on my wall I can't throw a
pizza party for my students what else
can I do and so what we recommend is
trying some of building on some of those
same concepts that work well in person
for your students try adapting them with
some of the tools you're using and
making them you know remote so if your
students are really encouraged
things like certificates or homework
passes and things like that again we
have a portfolio of certificates we can
share but don't let that limit you feel
free to you know recognize students with
certificates and if you can share them
digitally via email or a message app
through something like class dojo that
works really well or even if you got to
a point where you couldn't mail them to
students and they can recognize that and
show their class either by sharing maybe
through your Google classroom hey I got
this great certificate from my teacher
or you know if you some teachers prefer
things like video messages like using
flipgrid to show hey this is what my
students have done this week I'm really
proud of them even some simple things
are really inspiring like putting your
you know pet or your your own children
getting really excited about something
they've done or doing a silly dance we
have a teacher that we work really
closely with and he celebrates his
students by doing really you know things
that sound really terrible as adult like
walking on Legos or or things like
putting pie in his face recording
yourself doing some of these really
funny things that you can still do while
in your own home and sharing them to
students if you reach this goal I will
do this thing put it on a video and
share it with you showing that York
staying committed to learning just as
much as your students are oh I want to
share this comment from Linda which was
that I know I was I thought I was the
only one who was feeling overwhelmed and
it's so glad to know that I'm not alone
so Linda and everyone else out there
know that we were totally in the same
boat Megan and I are both former
teachers current parents with their own
kids at home so we absolutely feel what
you're going through and want to do
anything we can to support you during
this tough time that being said I do
want to call out because there are a lot
of questions coming in on this on the
question line that this is all being
recorded it'll be available in your
email automatically in about three hours
after the recording is processed you
will get that no questions asked
you can also grab all the slides that
Megan's already shared right now in the
handout section and if you can't find
that don't worry it'll also be included
in the email coming in three hours so
one way or another you'll get access to
all this and yes you can absolutely
share it with anyone okay Minna wants to
ask when you were talking about sort of
the time on Kahn account
per week were you recommending 30 to 45
minutes per week what was the
recommendation again there yeah so when
we talk about a lot of times we focus
more on in-class practice but even
thinking about that
again we don't want students to feel
overwhelmed by you know singing in front
of a screen for eight hours a day or
things like that and it shouldn't be
just Khan Academy we encourage you to
have some diversity and what students
are learning and especially if you were
an upper school teacher right
you're probably subject specific and you
don't want your students just doing that
one thing all day and so what we see is
that 30 to 45 active minutes on Khan
Academy per week shows really great
efficacy and so what you can look for as
a teacher in terms of tracking is that
on that report I shared and I'll just go
back on my screen to show you so if you
go back and you go to your teacher
dashboard and look at your activity
overview and you want to see in this
total learning minutes column you want
to see somewhere between 30 and 45
minutes and then in this skills leveled
up column you want to see two or more we
find that that's a really good benchmark
for seeing if students are making
meaningful progress great okay and to go
along with that Bridger asks this
question for an English or math teacher
could you give a brief summation and
what a week might look like including
assignments so basically walk me through
how that flow would look what I'm doing
what the students are doing so it feels
really real and doable for me sure now I
do want to say again you know your
classroom and your students best so
please adapt and don't take this as a
hard and fast rule but take it as
general advice that you can adapt to
your own teaching and your students
learning styles so if you're looking for
you know let's say a maths teacher right
Khan Academy has great math content from
pre-k through early college and so if
you're looking at something like that we
recommend some time again you still want
to be teaching your students so if you
can make sure you're getting live or
recorded videos of you talking through
some of those concepts at least a couple
times
and so how long that takes you now I
wasn't saying how much time your
students have access to Internet into
those tools might vary a little bit but
we'd say at least two or three times per
week trying to get that to them and then
when you're looking at what would I give
my students and again I recommend
looking at our resources to walk through
some of these skills on Khan Academy a
little bit more slowly but if you're
looking to make an assignment in this
case if I wanted to assign let's say
third grade content to my class if I
were looking for what I wanted to do for
the week
I might make three to five exercise
based assignments plus if I felt like
there was any sort of learning content
that might be helpful so if I were
looking at one digit multiplication I
can open up this unit and open up each
lesson and I can see the exercises that
would be there and if you look on the
right-hand side for our teachers these
are the common core standards to the
right-hand side so if you're looking for
specific standards you can find them
right here in the assignments feature or
you can search by those as well
so to get back to your question I would
probably make three to five assignments
for the week for students and I would
have them do one day like I would pick
one day probably at the end of the week
and I would also communicate with my
students that I'm not gonna be looking
at how well you performed until this day
so you're giving students the
opportunity to go back and try again and
really persevere through things they
might be struggling with or you know
they might need additional time to you
know learn those skills so this circle
all the way back I would say recommend
making sure there's some sort of
teaching or communication component two
or three times a week and then giving
students three to five assignments
hoping that they'll reach that 30 to 45
minute per week threshold and move up to
skills or more awesome a lot of
questions are coming in about sort of
how do you use Khan Academy for
differentiation and in particular how do
you serve special education students
particularly during this really tough
time any recommendations there Megan
oh really tough questions but I'm really
glad to hear them so when it comes to
differentiation we strongly encourage
teachers to enable our mastery system
and to set mastery goals with students
and here's why if you go into course
mastery again from this teacher
dashboard you go to placement you can
see the goals that are assigned to each
of your students and what you're able to
do is assign of course mastery goal to
all of your students just a subgroup of
your students or maybe just one of your
students so in the example you see on
your screen I've assigned Algebra one to
my whole class and I've assigned
pre-algebra to four of my students and
so the reason I assigned algebra
whatever and that's my class level goal
and this shows up on the student
dashboard for all of them every time
they log in it's one really big goal but
how they get to that goal varies by
every student so instead of having to
make an individual assignment for every
skill they need to learn you've given
them the opportunity to reach mastery on
all of those skills but they can do it
at their own pace and they're able to
watch videos and read articles on
concepts they can go back and review
skills that they may have had a gap in
or they can move ahead if they really
understand you know graphing equations
well and they can move quickly through
that they have the opportunity to take a
unit test and move really quickly and
move on to the next concept so that way
you're getting all students towards this
grade-level huge goal while giving them
the opportunity to work at their
personalized pace and get the supports
they need and then if you have students
who might need a little bit more support
maybe they're working below grade level
you can always assign an additional goal
and say you know what I'd really love
for you to get to 50% on pre-algebra
because I think you really need some
extra support in these skills and so
students can have the opportunity again
to go back and revisit content that
might feel you note below grade level
per se but they can do it at their own
pace and they can see themselves growing
and in achieving mastery and skills that
they might not have
and before and as I mentioned earlier
some teachers for students that are
progressing at a faster pace will
encourage to them to you know work on
the next course or work on something
else Khan Academy has content across you
know math science computer programming
arts and humanities and many others so
that sometimes when the students have
that you know additional time allow them
to learn even beyond that when it comes
to our special education students I will
say this is that we have I was gonna say
I would say we have an opportunity to
learn more about some best practices
with special education students but I
can reference a teacher I've worked
closely with before who has used Khan
Academy for multiple years in math for a
classroom entirely of special education
students and while those students in
terms of age might fall into what you
think of as middle school students
they're working on a first second grade
level and so what she's able to do is
that for each of her students she
creates a separate mastery goal for each
student based on to where she knows they
are and then each student is able to
work on the skills that feel appropriate
for them but the whole class is working
on mastery so all of the students feel
really included they're working towards
great big goals but they're all still
working on the skills that feel
appropriate for them and so in that
similar way when we talked about kind of
a standard classroom I would I would
offer the opportunity to think about how
you might be able to alter that for
special education students and if as you
go through this process you learn things
about that please reach out to us and
let us know how it goes because we are
always eager for teacher feedback to
improve our recommendations around any
area that's awesome and I'm sort of a
book on question of that this coming
from melody and many other educators is
okay I have a sign these course mastery
goals how do I measure progress what
reports do I look at what do I focus on
on the page how do I know how my
students are doing yeah what a great
question and I know that there's a lot
to take in here and I do encourage you
these are really great Khan Academy
questions to integrate some of what
we're sharing with what you're already
doing again
you are here
because you really care about your
students and really teaching well in
this new remote situation so please take
these pieces and integrate them with
things that you know that you're already
doing well so how you're tracking your
students and making sure they're getting
the best opportunities to learn and grow
please use those in combination with
what we're sharing so if I wanted to
specifically track progress on their
mastery goal if you look on the left
hand side where I'm at placement if I
instead choose progress
I can see here this is how my whole
class is doing in third grade so if I've
set the mastery goal here is third grade
I can see how much progress all of my
students have made and I can see a class
median so we've made about 8% progress
and if I hover over any of these bars
it'll show me which students quickly
fall into each of these areas so if I
look here Jocelyne and when Bo fall into
this first box we're looking at you know
ten to twenty percent whereas if I jump
up here I can see melissa is at you know
forty four percent so that gives you a
quick snapshot of all of your class and
how they're doing towards that greater
goal if you scroll down below you'll see
each of the units within that overall
course and it will give you a class
median on how they're doing on each of
those units so in this case if I clicked
into one digit multiplication I now get
a similar screen to what I saw for
course mastery but I get it at the unit
level and so here I can see how much
progress have my students made in this
particular unit we've made a little bit
more progress here you can see and the
same hover opportunity exists and then
if I really want to get detailed if I
scroll below these chart I'll see this
section called skill mastery and it
shows me exactly where my students fall
for every specific skill by clicking the
caret on the left hand side it shows me
my students and how they're performing
on that particular skill so my first
buck will be not started meaning
students haven't done anything yet
attempted means they've tried but
they've gotten fewer than 70% of those
questions correct familiar and means
they've reached at least 70 proficient
if means they've got at least a hundred
percent on an exercise which is single
skill practice and to get to mastered
they have to show that they have success
in both a single skill practice of the
exercise and a mixed skill practice of
either the unit test or the course
challenge so they have to be able to
demonstrate that skill in
isolation and combined with other skills
and what's neat about this part of the
progress report is that if you see
students that have not started this
skill or might need more practice if you
click the assign button on the left hand
side a pop-up box will appear and
without you having to search for it
you can assign that skill to either all
your class a handful of students or a
single student and encourage them to
work on that skill to master it very
cool so hopefully that gives you a sense
of how you can keep tabs on your
students even when you're all spread
apart but now we've pretty deep into the
innards of Khan Academy let's zoom back
a little bit Sheila and a couple of
others are asking hey is there an answer
sheet for Khan Academy how do I actually
evaluate how things are doing can you
just maybe show off a sample practice
exercise Meghan just to show the kind of
experience the students get really
wonderful questions Sheila and so let me
address your question in a couple parts
so first of all there's no grading
required for the teacher or if you're a
parent on the line with us right now
everything is greeted for you so no
one's gonna quiz you on your Algebra one
skills if it's benefit but if you're
looking for more detail if you go to
make an assignment so let's go back into
my class and if I go to assignments and
under that I click assign and so if I
look at any of these exercises from the
teacher perspective if I click on the
title of the exercise what I see is an
item Bank and it will show me all the
questions students can receive if I
assign this exercise and when you assign
it you have two options you can assign
all the same questions to students and
all students will receive the same exact
questions or random questions which
means students will receive random
questions out of the item Bank however I
will give the caveat that if students if
you choose random if there's different
types of questions so in this case you
can see there is a number line question
and there it's this box question all
students will receive the same number
questions of the same type so they won't
be totally different it's more that the
variables are changed and so in this
case students would receive seven of
these twenty-one questions and we
encourage teachers to take a look at the
item bag before they assign the students
to see is this the right skill I'm
looking for does this feel like the
right level of rigor for my students are
there any pitfall questions I should
tell my students to look out for and so
here's where you could find it's not
quite an answer key but it is a good
item back of what your students would
see and from the student view if you
click here you see this is what it looks
like from the student perspective here's
the question and then below they can get
supports to watch a video or use a hint
and once you make those assignments to
students you can look at their scores
right below that assign you can look at
scores and what you'll be able to see is
how they've performed on each assignment
you've made and if it is a video or an
article you've assigned to the student
they'll receive a checkmark for
completing that for an article they just
open the article and scroll down for a
video they have to watch at least 90
percent of the video and they can't
watch it faster than double speed if
they try and watch it at triple or
quadruple speed they won't get credit
for it and then for anything that has
questions a quiz and exercise a unit
test they'll get a numeric value for
that and it will be color coded for you
so if they are below 70% it'll come up
in red if it's between 70 and 99 it'll
come up in this yellow color and then if
it's a hundred percent they'll get a
nice screen and by clicking on any of
those individual scores you can view the
report for that student so you can
really view it at a class level or jump
in and view it at a student level and
here you can see the questions the
student was given and then what their
answer was and so if the student if
you've selected randomly ordered these
questions are ordered by the ones they
missed most and here's the thing is it
you can also change this on the top
right right
now I'm looking at a single student
right now I'm looking at Michael but if
I wanted I could select them all and
what I can do here is that I can look at
either their first or last attempt and
because I selected random I can see the
questions in order by most miss so if I
see here question five students had the
greatest challenge with this question I
can use this question for a reteach and
maybe it's an opportunity to do that
quick video that I either record and
share out or do it live on a whiteboard
with them and work through the problem
and if you're looking for supports on
you know maybe how do I look at this in
the same way that we offer hints to
students we provide that same
walkthrough set of hints to teachers if
you wanted to display this again maybe
in a recorded video or live with
students here's the walkthrough steps
you can use cool well speaking of
recorded videos Paul has a very juicy
inside Khan Academy question for us
which is today know what kind of
software Sal Khan uses to make those
videos and if it you want to make their
own console
I do not know the software style uses
that's a great question I have been here
a few years and no one has asked me that
so Bravo on asking me a question I
haven't been asked yet I will definitely
find that out however what I can share
with you some of the tools that I use to
make videos for teachers and so a couple
of things that are free one you can do
some recording with hangout meets loom
LOM is a free tool you can use that
allows you to record your screen and
your face at the same time that I really
like again that's just something that
I've used in some of our colleagues have
used and it's great for doing things
like I just demonstrated so walking
through this and it also can have a
video of your face in the corner so your
students can see you you know what
you're doing on your screen so maybe
they're gonna you're modeling a behavior
for them and they still get to see your
face cuz they probably miss you that's
so cool I'll just add that from having
sat in Sal's off as a couple weeks ago
before we're all sent home I know he
uses a Wacom tablet
so check those out and add them to your
next Amazon delivery of hand sanitizer
and toilet paper okay so great question
Paul um another sort of interesting
technical question this is come from
Frank and a number of others is okay I
love Kahn but I'm also using Google
classroom or Schoology or canvases of my
lms there's someone to at least get like
the Kahn links into my LMS system yeah
that's a request we get a lot and it's
something that me as a team I think is
really important as you know to think
about as we move forward currently we do
not fully integrate with any of the
learning management systems so what we
do allow is that you can import your
class roster through Google classroom so
there's no need for you to create a
classroom scratch you can simply pull in
your roster from Google classroom and
students can use Google single sign-on
however sharing the assignments directly
we have not established that link with
any LMS is yet however I do know our
friends at class dojo have shared that
if you're using class dojo and you make
an assignment you can put the direct
link to the assignment in there and
share that really easily with students
it's a really important concept that you
bring out and it's really important
especially now but we do not link
assignments directly with any learning
management systems at the time cool I
will just mention that like even though
you would lose some of the power of the
assignments we just talked about if
you're ever just in rush so like I've
got to get some of my students fast the
clock is ticking every single piece of
content on Khan Academy has a unique URL
that little sort of web address at the
top and of course you can always copy
and paste a video link or an exercise
link if you just want to stick it right
at your LMS but of course there is an
advantage to using Khan Academy natively
to have all that evaluation okay so a
couple of challenges that teachers are
facing right now big one that we've
heard a lot today is help you know my
students don't all have internet access
at home or devices at home are there any
workarounds or there any way to get them
access to all this goodness that you're
talking about yeah I think that that has
become more apparent to everyone in the
current situation that how the way we
think about internet and device
accessibility is really become you know
more apparent than I think the priority
has been in the past and so while Khan
Academy is really dependent on students
being able to have some form of internet
access to get those personalized results
to help them differentiate and get what
they need to either review or move
forward there are a couple things we can
recommend the one is that if students
have access even to just a smartphone
what we found is that a lot of families
might not have a laptop or they might
not have a tablet but someone in the
home has a smartphone Khan Academy has
an app and all of the features that are
available to students on the website are
available through the app and the app is
available in eighteen different
languages so even if students want their
parents who might not have grown up in
the u.s. education system to support
them they can work with them and so
that's one piece we can recommend a
second one is there is some information
on our Help Center site that I recommend
is that what it is there's an article
I'm sure I can pull it up right now
actually on how do I use Khan Academy
without an internet connection and so
here it'll show you how to use some of
the apps and you can download the video
if students only maybe have a limited
amount of internet connection they can
download the videos from the app and
watch them at a later time and there's
also collaboration with an organization
organization we work with called Calibri
and they allow devices to download
content including Khan Academy to
download exercises videos articles ahead
of time and then watch them or engage
them at a later point in time again that
would involve a device still an internet
access at some point but it wouldn't
involve a consistent flow of Internet
connectivity cool and then through Pia
backing on that linguistic challenge
that you were talking about Angelina
asks you as an ESL teacher in an
elementary school a lot of my students
just don't speak English how
and I leveraged Khan Academy given that
most of the stuff that we've seen so far
is in English yeah absolutely what a
phenomenal question and we work with
school districts all over the US and our
team is international and so we are
thinking about how do we serve anyone
anywhere and really deliver a
world-class education and that is not
just in English and so we are available
in 40-plus languages and let me show you
quickly how students can change their
language setting and we see this in
school districts inside the u.s. really
frequently and we want families and
communities to be able to support their
learners so even if they're encouraged
to learn in English in the classroom
they can change their language at home
so their parents and community can
support their learning process and then
switch it back to English in your
classroom so if you click on the name
and this would be the same process for a
student as it would be for a teacher so
they click on their name in the top
right and they go to settings and one of
the top things at on the settings page
here is it says primary language and if
you click the drop-down you'll see here
that we have over 40 languages for
learners to choose from I'm gonna stay
in English and then make sure here's the
important part you click Save Changes
and it says information updated in green
that's how you know the language has
switched so if I were to switch it it
would change the core language on the
site I and most of our content
especially if you're looking for Spanish
speakers ah almost all of our content
that's in English is available in
Spanish and then large percentages for
all of those other languages very cool
and so just to end I may be one really
Universal question that folks are
thinking about right now is whether
you're a teacher and you're trying to
serve the families all around your
community who are now spread out or
you're also a parent and you're trying
to serve your own students at home any
recommendations Megan for how to really
support your students whether they're
your kids or your students in your
classroom without overstepping bounds
without sort of being too overbearing
and saying hey you've got
do this work even when the world is a
little bit of a chaotic state yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna go back to what I
mentioned earlier is it's just being
open about it right this is hard for all
of us and so I think it was really good
and the example I said earlier where the
Khan Academy team was like listen we're
really trying to help what these tools
are new for us too and we're trying and
people are right yeah I'm trying to and
owning that shared experience that this
is hard and so I think being able to be
open with your students and say you know
what I want you to achieve this and
here's why and giving them that really
good reason and being like it's okay if
you struggle it's okay if it's
frustrating and you know accepting that
this is an opportunity for for us all to
grow together and and don't hesitate as
I said you know to reach out if you've
got great ideas or we as an organization
you can do more to support you because
we really do think we are stronger
together cool well I know we're almost
at time I know we have barely scratched
the surface of all the questions that
have come in so thank you so much for
asking such great ones yeah maybe
would you mind sort of closing up with
showing folks where they can go on the
Help Center to ask questions directly to
our amazing support team sure that
sounds great Jeremy so if you navigate
to our Help Center which is Khan
Academy's end Escom the link is on the
last slide in the slide deck that's
shared from this webinar and here you
can search for any sort of content you
might have questions on and you'll be
able to see information around
frequently asked questions community
responses and if you have a technical
problem or something that's not quite
right if you click report a problem
you'll be taking to this request form
and our support team is really
phenomenal and even in this hi request
time they've still been answering
requests in under a couple hours so
please if you have any questions or if
you things aren't working quite right
for you please reach out to us we always
want to hear from you also any
words of wisdom Megan as folks heading
to the weekend after there's a very very
long week you know what give yourself a
pat on the back it's been a long hard
week for everyone and you know what be
proud of the fact that you've gotten
through it and you've learned something
and you know what next week you can
you've learn something this week and
look forward to learning something new
next week cause as we say at Khan
Academy we're always learning
we're always discovering new things and
we always end every session by saying
onward so we wish you a wonderful
weekend and onwards to all Thanks
you